five in the morning no it's my favorite
uh Emperor quote Revenge of the Sith
anywho guys we got a rise a Skywalker
special look we're gonna cover this
right now before we go into that I
wanted to say thank you once again to
all ya beautiful sons of bastards who
have followed us on the Stardust app
over there with you thirty second
reaction reviews for any film TV show
and/or trailer we post regularly you can
post to the whole thing is completely
free to download and use free stuff is
better than any stuff so I say do it
today
link in description box could waste any
more time more Disney stuff
[Music]
stop
[Music]
we really are coming full circle are we
as long as they're good
[Music]
we passed along
a thousand generations
this is your fight this is all raised
vision right here
Sierra completely out the fridge
the whole game and Wow
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
Wow dissect that one I heard about a
double-bladed I heard about it don't
realize gonna go thank you warm like
that kind of like a Darth Maul
lightsaber you can either have it be two
lightsabers up here that are hard to
hold or one double-edged lace I wonder
if that's real they wouldn't just give
away something like that in the trailer
what they the rages turns bad or
Orwell's like there's gotta be like a
vision or a vision or they change the
rules or something you know yeah because
I've heard that theory that Skywalker
Rises Skywalker could be in reference to
kylo Ren you know because he's an actual
Skywalker
by blood could be referenced that it
would be it would be a cool flip I just
feel like they wouldn't give that away
in the trailer and yeah yeah you know
what I mean especially cuz I'm like
wondering how it all lines up you got
that epic battle fight that they've been
teasing especially on that poster oh you
know where they're like on a ship and
there's water with kylo and Rey and I
just seems like it would be a finale
fight right yeah unless it's the
prologue of the movie but still that is
an epic tease for what's to come
something about her having the whole
thing with you know being robed and
having the dark lightsaber it kind of
reminds me a little bit of Empire
Strikes Back when Luke has a vision I
know it's more reference to though
that's my dad or something like that
when Luke imagines his face inside of
Darth Vader's helmet when he like
battles him but it's not real and that's
kind of more the impression that I'm
getting but I also love the trailer edit
raipur leading into that moment because
you hear even the the the Darth Vader
breathing we're just like it's so brief
so subtle because you're also pay
attention to what the emperor saying
about your journeys coming to it and
also like throwing in all the footage of
the previous Star Wars movies this is
supposed to be the actual conclusion to
it all and
it's pretty cool to see how they're even
really heavily acknowledging the
prequels I was like once that montage
got to a certain point I was like okay
are we just going to revisit the
original films but yeah I mean it does
like even for his poorly received as the
prequels kind of worried does feel like
I hope they nail this because it does
feel like the big culmination of a giant
multi-decade saga and now I'm just
sitting here going great script wise if
we're going to come back in ten years
and be like this is the sequel that
ignores all the later sequels and so I
just don't want that I mean it goes
without saying that it's shot incredibly
well beautiful I love those sequences
that they were teasing of when they're
in the like it's nighttime and they're
they're not it doesn't look like they're
actually in space look they're in the
clouds but they're gonna have like a sky
looks like a long time it looks really
cool battles yeah a lot of dark peril
well yeah I've got that giant red laser
beam it looks like they're gonna fire
off whatever massive or Buehler weapon
they oh yeah well now that that was
introduced in force and I think it's the
same one from force awakens from but due
to pulling an all-nighter I can't quite
remember the name of it right and also
seeing that shot of the group at the
beginning I feel like that's the same
planet that they were that was in the
teaser trailer when you see ray you know
getting ready to flip over that ship and
then also when you see them like Finn
and Poe and everybody back together but
not and the teaser trailer when they
have when they're like doing kind of
like it looks like a pirate like
pirating kind of mission yeah I think
that's all part of the same scene where
Zoe have made like 30 minutes of them
saying or something like that yeah and
it looks like to me I don't know I can
when she throws the lightsaber
boomerangs it back which is pretty
badass I wonder if she's kind of
training herself a little bit or maybe
that's one of the scenes with Luke as a
ghost team he's like I didn't really
teach you last time all the other force
gave me crap about this
do this right oh and the other thing too
was showing the previous footage one
thing that kind of dawned on me was how
you know kylo the the and tucks in he's
like obsessed with his grandfather Darth
Vader and the Emperor the whole thing
with you know kind of taking him under
his wing meaning a apprentice really
doing great my words right now is that
wiping the whole Anakin Skywalker
identity and you see a lot of Anakin
Skywalker and just in those flashback
moments it could just be oh we're a
Majin we're really setting up that this
is gonna complete the whole package or I
wonder if we're actually gonna see a you
know a kylo Ren learning a little bit
about you know the the humanity behind
Darth Vader with like how in Return of
the Jedi Darth Vader actually you know
came back to being Anakin at the end of
it all and that there was more than just
the image of evil Darth Vader that there
was a guy Anakin Skywalker and I wonder
if there's gonna be something that
happens there with maybe progressing or
changing kylo ren's character I don't
have I'm reading way too much into it it
just you know I mean I feel like it
could happen yeah yeah and I feel like
that's something that people have been
theorizing and chewing on since the
first you know since the force awakens
came out is sort of how are these going
to go the way we expect it to with Rey
being just the light side you know
archetype and yeah hello being the red
but you're kylo being the you know dark
side but I don't know for as much as
that's been an issue I got to imagine
that maybe they won't take us exactly
the direction that we're expected with
him them etc I mean yeah it does seem
like a little much to show if that's if
Rey is gonna turn to the dark side seem
a little much to show that in the teaser
but I feel like one of the big remaining
mysteries of this franchise has been
where is kylo and ray where are they
gonna end up and I wouldn't be surprised
if there was some kind of unexpected
twist there are unexpected develop
there's some kind of Hobbit of an
unexpected journey yeah and my favorite
part of this trailer it's the way it
really builds off the last Jedi's
promise of letting the past time
totally for moving alright guys well are
you excited for Star Wars the last Jedi
what are your theories put them down in
the comments below and tell us
everything that we missed on this one
view you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
belt don't forget to download and follow
us on the stardust app before I wrap
this up I'd like to give a patron today
shout to a very special man his name is
Philip J Smith jr. home boys all the way
from Long Island New York he's a
volunteer firefighter and he hasn't
responded to me in a while so per
tradition I looked up his name Philip
and I found out it means friend lover
and friend of horses so my man if I
don't hear some news report about some
mysterious firefighter who's making love
to horses in Long Island and then taking
them out for you know like a nice dinner
afterwards I'm just saying you're uh
you're letting me down dude you're
letting me down you gotta let that
little Skywalker rise into a horse honor
your name
I'm vigilant and watchful that's my name
so I'm looking out for you to be doing
the right thing the shoutout could have
been better